I'm Erik Demaine.
You can call me Erik.
This is the web
page for the class.
You should all go there if you
haven't already, and sign up
on this sheet if you want
to be on the mailing list.
Good.
So, maybe I'll tell you a little
bit what this class about.
Then I'll tell you about
how the class works,
and then we'll do more
about what it's about.
The idea of lecture 1 is
to cover the entire class
in one lecture.
Obviously, I will omit
a few of the details
because we have a
lot to cover, but I
thought it would
be fun to give you
a picture what the whole class
is, what the sort of content
is, so you know whether
you want to be here.
And my chalk.
So this class is about geometry.
It's about folding.
It's about algorithms.
In general, we are interested in
the mathematics and algorithms
behind folding things.
And also unfolding things,
because that turns out
to be pretty interesting.
And the formal term for
things is geometric objects.
And you think of things
like your arm folds.
Pieces of paper fold.
All sorts of things
fold in the world.
A lot of the-- if there's
any sheet metal objects
in this room, maybe
some of these parts
are folded out of sheet.
I would guess so.
So folding is everywhere,
and this class
is all about how that
works mathematically.
And I'm a theoretical
computer scientist.
I do algorithms, so my
slant is towards algorithms,
which is getting computers
to do all this for you.
How many people here
are computer scientists?
How many people are-- you've got
to pick one-- mathematicians?
How many people are
neither of the above?
Wow, cool.
It's like not a lot of
mathematicians only,
but a lot of
computer scientists,
a lot of everyone else.
So I'll go around later
maybe and find out
what your background is.
You may be interested
less in the mathematics
and more in the
applications, so let
me tell you a little
bit about those.
I have a long list of
applications, some of which
have been realized,
some of which
are still in progress
or just ideas.
Robotics is a big one,
folding robotic arms.
And I'll show later different
kinds of transforming robots,
like Transformers or
Terminator 2-style, where
you want one robot to take on
many different forms, this idea
of programmable matter,
where you can program
the geometry of your
object as well as you
could program the software.
So next time when you
buy the new iPhone,
you download the
hardware in addition
to downloading software.
That would be the crazy idea.
That, of course,
doesn't exist yet.
But it exists in
some simple forms.
Computer graphics.
If you're making
Toy Story 4, and you
want to animate your characters
from one position to another,
you have some skeleton
which is a foldable object,
and you'd like to interpolate
between two key frames
that the animator
draws automatically.
That's a morphing problem,
and it's a folding morphing
problem.
We have mechanics.
A lot of the early folding
work is in like 17, 1800s,
and is motivated by
building mechanical linkages
to do useful things.
This is back before
electrical computers,
we had mechanical
computers of sorts.
Things like you could sign
your name in triplicate
by just signing once,
and having a linkage that
made many copies of it.
I think Jefferson
used such a linkage.
We have manufacturing, which
is a pretty broad term--
things like sheet metal bending.
Nano manufacturing, I think,
is an exciting context,
where you can-- we're
really good at building
flat nano-scale
objects like CPUs.
And if you could
get them to fold up,
then you could manufacture
3D nano-scale objects.
I have optics here, Jason.
Sure.
George [INAUDIBLE] group
does some optical devices
through folding here at MIT.
Medical is a big one.
Imagine folding a
stent really small,
so it can fit through
small blood vessels
until it gets to where
you want in your body
and expands-- do
non-intrusive heart surgery.
Drug delivery is another one.
You have some object you want
to deliver, your cancer drug,
so it follows through your body
until it detects the cancer,
and then it releases
the drug, for example.
Something we just
started looking at.
Aero-astro.
You want to deploy something
out in outer space.
You've got to get it there
first within the space shuttle.
So how do you fold
it down small so it
fits in your space
shuttle, and then expands
when it gets there?
Biology.
Big one.
I'm interested in
protein folding.
Proteins are the building block
of all life forms we know,
and we'd like to
know how they fold.
I'll show you some
pictures of them later.
We'll talk more
about it, obviously,
in the rest of the class.
And the goal is to use
this mathematics of folding
to try to figure out what
biology might be doing
in real life, though that's
still obviously very difficult.
Sculpture, sort
of an obvious one.
Designing cooler
origami is possible,
thanks to mathematics
and algorithms.
Hopefully Jason agrees.
Jason Ku is, I guess, the top
origami designer currently
at MIT.
That's a safe bet.
You could make
some broader claim.
And we'll get him to
give a guest lecture
on the more artistic
side of origami,
and I'll talk about the
mathematics-- some of which
is currently used
in origami design
today, either implicitly or
explicitly, some of which
is yet to be used, but hopefully
will make cooler sculpture.
You could also imagine
building interactive sculpture.
Interactive buildings'
architecture
is another big one.
How many people
here are architects?
Cool.
A bunch.
So I think this is really
exciting and underexploited
at the moment,
reconfigurable buildings.
Hoberman is one
example of somebody
exploring this, getting the
building to fold from one shape
to another, or getting your
shades to fold from one shape
to another, all sorts of things.
That's all I have.
Maybe there are more.
You're welcome to tell me.
But this is somehow
why you might
care about the mathematics
of folding things.
And what else do I have?
Yeah, let me tell you a
little bit about the field.
It's, in some sense, old.
There are some problems in
this world of geometric folding
that go back four
or five centuries.
And some of those problems
are still unsolved,
but a lot of the
action in the field
has been in the
last 12 years or so.
And it's been really exciting.
A lot of theorems
have been proved.
In fact, a lot of
theorems have been
proved in the context
of previous iterations
of this class.
And so I always have
to update things,
because we keep
getting new results.
And the idea of this class
is to cover the bleeding
edge, whatever the
frontiers of what's known,
and also to push
that edge further.
So there is an open problem
session, which is optional.
But if you want to come solve
new problems that haven't been
solved before,
every week probably
we'll work on a problem related
to what I cover in class.
So you know what's
known, and then we
try to prove what's unknown.
That's the idea.
And that's worked
pretty well in the past.
Let's dive a little
bit into the sort
of mathematical structures.
So say geometric objects.
There are three main
things that we typically
think about, linkages, pieces
of paper, and polyhedra.
A linkage is something like
your arm or a robotic arm.
You have one-dimensional
straight links like bones,
and hinges that
connect them together.
And you'd like to know
how that thing can fold.
So this is like in the graphics
world or mechanical linkage
world.
The typical way we
think about linkages
is that they have rigid bars.
As opposed to a string,
which is really floppy,
here you have these rigid,
like maybe metal, parts,
and you can only
fold at the hinges.
That's typical
thinking on linkages.
Makes it interesting.
And sometimes we also
require no crossing.
I'm trying to take a physical
thing you have intuition for,
and write some of the
mathematical constraints.
No crossing means you
can't intersect yourself.
Sometimes that's important.
Sometimes it's not.
In a lot of the
mechanical linkage world
you can have crossing
bars, but just
because they're in different
planes in real life,
if you're making a
two-dimensional linkage.
Paper.
This is my drawing
of a piece of paper.
The rules are you
are not allowed
to stretch the
material, and you're not
allowed to tear or cut.
So all you can do is fold.
And so intuitively
this is saying
you can't make paper any longer.
You can't really
make it shorter.
The only thing you can do
is change its 3D geometry.
But if you look really closely,
the geometry is the same.
It has a fixed
intrinsic geometry.
All the distances on the
surface are staying the same.
And usually in modern
origami, you're
not allowed to cut the
paper, because that
makes things too
easy, basically.
And I guess also
no crossing here.
It's a requirement.
This is a pretty informal
description of paper.
You can formalize it.
We will do that at some point.
But it's pretty intuitive.
You've all done it before.
Polyhedron is something
more three-dimensional.
So here we had one-dimensional
things we were folding.
Two-dimensional things
we were folding.
A three-dimensional thing, or at
least a two-dimensional surface
in three dimensions,
a typical thing
you might want to do with
a polyhedron is build it.
And often you want to
build something out
of flat material, something
like-- you've probably
made a cube by building a
cross, and then folding it up
into that thing.
That's the folding problem.
The unfolding problem
is, where do I
cut along this surface
in order to make
one of these nice unfoldings?
I think there's one more
cut here in the back.
If I did it right, that
will unfold into the cross.
So if I have some complicated
3D shape, what 2D shape
do I cut out in order to
bend it into that 3D shape?
That's the unfolding problem.
There are actually
lots of different kinds
of polyhedron folding
problems, but here it
is you want to cut the surface.
You want one piece-- it's
a little harder to assemble
multiple pieces-- and you'd like
no overlap in that unfolding.
Because if, when you
unfold, it overlaps,
then you can't
actually make it out
of one piece of sheet material.
So these are the sorts
of things we study.
And I think the
plan in the class
is I will start with paper,
because it's kind of the most
fun, origami design,
computational origami design.
And then we'll talk about
linkages and polyhedra.
And I'll probably jump around
from week to week, just
to keep it exciting, because
they're all interesting.
You might each have
your favorite one.
And so that we can talk
about all of them at once.
So what kind of
mathematical questions
would you ask about
these structures?
Well, there are two main
types I like to characterize.
On the one hand, we have what
I call foldability questions,
where you're given some existing
structure like a linkage,
or a piece of paper with
some creases on it maybe,
and you'd like to know,
how does that thing fold?
So I give you some structure,
and you'd like to know,
does it fold?
Maybe just does it fold at all?
Or, in some particular
way, can you
make it fold into
something interesting?
Or some notion of interesting?
I'm going to be generic
here, because there's
a lot of different
questions obviously.
And this is in contrast
to a design question,
where you're given-- what
you start with is a goal.
Like I want to make a butterfly.
And then the question is, how
do I fold a piece of paper
to make that butterfly?
So here you're given
maybe a crease pattern
and given some structure.
You want to see how it folds.
In design, you're
given the goal and you
want to figure out
what you should build,
what folding structure
should I make
that will achieve this goal?
So what shapes?
Shape is one thing
you might want.
But in general, you have some
property you want to achieve.
Can you fold it?
And of course if you
can, how do you do it?
So this tends-- in
general you could
think of this as a more
mathematical question, this
as a more algorithmic question.
But usually actually
both of them
are addressed with
algorithms to some extent.
Of course design
is somehow cooler,
but often we need to
understand foldability
before we can solve design.
But not always.
It depends.
And just to give
you like-- I mean
if you looked at the entire
set of results, the questions
and answers, that we consider,
and you filter them down,
there would be three
kinds of things
that we prove in this class.
These are the results.
All the results
in three bullets.
It could be either
you get universality.
This is the coolest
kind of result,
and it's surprisingly common.
Everything can be folded, for
some notion of everything.
That's always a challenge.
And you get an
algorithm to do it.
So if you say I want
to fold a butterfly,
you put the butterfly
into the algorithm,
out come your design
for folding a butterfly.
That's the ideal picture when
you get a universality result.
The next best thing
you could hope for
is a sort of decision
result, which
is that there's a fast
algorithm that will tell you
whether something is foldable.
So we say it
decides foldability.
So you give it a butterfly.
It says, oh, that's impossible.
That's not true.
But you could imagine that.
Or maybe you give it a
butterfly, it says yes.
You give it the
skyline of New York,
and it says no, you
can't fold that.
That's not true.
But if it's not the case
that everything is foldable,
the next best thing is you
could at least distinguish
which things are foldable
from which things are not.
And then, of course,
the worst thing that
could happen, in some sense,
is you get a hardness results
which says, there's no good
way to even distinguish
foldable things from
unfoldable things.
So I'm going to
say computationally
intractable to mean generically
that there's no good algorithm
to solve a problem.
We're going to be more formal
about that in the future.
Because different people
have different backgrounds,
you may know about
competition complexity.
Many of you don't.
That's cool.
We're going to talk
about all that here.
All right.
That's the class in a nutshell.
Totally generic.
Any questions so far?
Probably not.
I thought now I would tell you
a little bit about the class
structure.
The main part of the
class are these lectures,
and attendance is
mandatory for classes,
because you're not going to
learn it unless you come here.
You can have exceptions.
Just email me and
watch the videos later.
That's one of the fun
features of the videos,
although the videos are mainly
to reach the world for fun.
There will be a few problem sets
in this class, not too many.
And the other main thing that
you turn in is the project.
So sort of a
project-focused class.
You will hand in some write up.
You will give some presentation
in the last few lectures
of class, if you're taking
the class for credit.
If you're listening, you
don't have to do this.
You can, if you want.
You can do the problem sets.
Some of them will be fun.
Hopefully all of
them will be fun.
None of them will
bee too painful.
But for people who are
taking the class for credit,
you have to do a project
and presentation.
The project could be
about tons of things.
You could build a sculpture.
You could come up with a cool
virtual design of something
amazing that somehow
relates to folding.
It doesn't have to be direct.
If you're a coder, you could
implement some algorithm
we talk about, or make a
beautiful image or animation
or applet or something.
If you're more theory, you
could solve an open problem.
Obviously that's a big win.
But even trying to solve
an open problem is fine.
You can talk about how
you failed to solve it,
in the unhappy
case that happens.
But if you want to
solve an open problem,
I would encourage you to come
to the open problem session,
so we can all solve it together.
Then you can have
a joint project
on what we do, but it's totally
unpredictable, of course.
Even posing an open
problem in this field
is pretty interesting.
I know a lot of the
hard open problems.
I would like to find more of
them, more tractable ones.
And so if you have some
idea, especially related
to some application field
that you know a lot about,
it'd be cool to try
to extract, what
is the mathematical problem
in a lot of these fields?
Or you can write a survey.
That's a typical project.
You should avoid overlap with--
I don't actually have it here,
but the textbook
for this class--
you can imagine it being
here-- is Geometric Folding
Algorithms.
Here it is.
Thank you, Jason.
That's good.
I ran out of copies.
Now I have one.
No, I'll give it back.
So this is by me and Joe
O'Rourke at Smith College.
Any questions about
class structure?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can projects be
individual? [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Projects
can be with groups.
I forget whether the
website has a limit
on the number of people.
I don't think so.
But at some point you'll have
to do a project proposal.
I should mention that also.
And then I will vet
your project group.
But I think anything's fine.
Just when you have
more people, you're
expected to do a
little more, naturally.
Other questions?
Yeah.
I love collaboration.
I think I've never written
a paper without a co-author.
It wasn't a survey paper.
So collaboration's good.
All right.
Doing well.
So the next thing I
want to do is actually
dive into actual content.
This was totally generic.
And to me, it's useful.
But maybe to you,
it's less useful.
This is sort of an organization.
As we go through,
everything you'll see
will fit almost always into
one of these three categories.
The question will fit into
one of these two categories,
and the answer will fit into
one of these three categories.
Now let's see what some of
those actual problems, questions
and answers, are.
That's the fun part.
There's so many
cool results here,
and so many cool open problems.
I thought I'd tell you a bunch
of the big open problems, too.
So in today's class, I'm
going to go in order.
We're going to start with
linkages, and then paper,
and then polyhedra.
And I'm going to start with
linkages allowing intersection.
So magically, bars of the
linkage can overlap each other.
And then later I'll
talk about linkages,
which is most interesting
in two dimensions,
because you can actually build
them in three dimensions.
And then we'll go to linkages
that do not have intersection.
So an early
motivation here where
a lot of this linkage folding
came from originally--
this is the 17, 1800s-- is
converting linear motion
into circular motion.
Actually, it's really--
yeah, get it right.
Linear motion to
circular motion.
I don't know what order
to cover these things.
I'll show you a slide.
My rules are essentially
no words on any slide.
This is just for
pretty pictures,
and I'll write
stuff on the board.
There's this fun book called
How to Draw a Straight
Line by Kempe in 1877, which
is all about this problem.
How do I turn a
circular crank and make
a straight line come
out as a result?
And the motivation for this
problem is steam engines.
You have a steam piston,
which is moving something
up and down along
a straight line.
And maybe you're building
a locomotive train,
and you want to turn
a wheel in a circle,
because wheels are round.
So how do you convert
this linear motion
into a circular motion?
That is How to Draw a Straight
Line, affectionately titled.
But you can see that one of
the earliest linkages for this
is called the Watt
parallel motion.
And we have a little
animation here.
So the idea is this vertex in
the top left is pinned down.
This one in the bottom
right is pinned down.
And then, I think if I move
this around the circle,
the green guy moves
along that figure eight.
And there's a limit
to how far it can go.
So and if you draw it
right, the figure eight
is almost a straight line.
So that was mathematics
back in the day.
No, no one thought
that that was perfect,
but it was pretty good.
And that actually led Watt--
you may have heard of Watt.
He's a unit.
And he was very proud
of this invention.
And he made tons of innovations
in the steam engine world,
and this was his favorite.
And, I mean, it changed things.
But later on-- I mean this
is like 100 years later,
1864 versus 1764.
Exactly 100 years later.
Peaucellier a French guy
in the army, I think,
came up with this linkage.
So again, you have two
pinned vertices here.
This one's moving
around a circle.
So you just turn
the crank, and look.
This guy moves
along that red line.
Perfect.
Very cool.
Again it has a limit
how far you can go.
But it's pretty awesome.
I mean you could play
with this forever.
I won't bore you.
There's this other
guy you may have heard
of, Kelvin, Lord Kelvin.
Another unit.
There's a story about
him playing with one.
He wouldn't want to
give it up, because he
was having too much fun just
pushing it back and forth.
It's like, wow, a straight
line out of a circle.
So that's pretty cool.
Making straight lines out
of circles is pretty neat.
In fact, you could think,
well, what else could I make?
I can make a straight line.
That's kind of nice.
But could I make, I don't
know, some other curve?
I mean a straight line is
a special kind of curve.
Maybe I could make this curve.
That's a nice curve.
In general, there's
a universality result
which says there's a
linkage to sign your name.
That's the cute phrasing.
So it's a
two-dimensional linkage.
You turn one circular crank,
and it signs your name.
The mathematical
version is that you
trace a piecewise
polynomial curve.
Or if you're an architect
or graphics person,
call this a spline.
Pick your favorite word.
You can make it all
with one linkage.
It's pretty crazy, and
not super practical.
Building this would probably
require thousands of bars.
But hey, who's counting?
At least you can get
a universality result.
This is actually
something that goes back,
in particular, to the
first time this class was
taught six years ago.
We found some better
ways to do, so it's
known that it could be done.
And I'll talk about
those ways later on.
Cool.
Open problem.
Not everything is known.
There's a lot of open
problems here, but one of them
is, what if you
forbid crossings?
So these linkages, like the
ones I've been showing here,
like the Peaucellier linkage,
there's crossing bars.
And yeah, you could do that, but
what if you forbid crossings?
It'd be really cool to sign
your name with a linkage that
doesn't even cross itself.
That's totally open.
Getting any kind of
result, positive result,
maybe not everything,
but at least
getting some interesting things.
Even drawing a straight
line, I think, is open.
Could be a fun
problem to work on.
All right.
That's one.
Let's go over here.
Let's see, is that the end
of linkages, is crossing?
No.
Next question you might
ask is-- so that's
sort of a design question.
I was given the goal, which
was to make a straight line
or sign my name.
And I wanted to find
the linkage that did it.
The other question, the
foldability question,
one of them is rigidity, which
is, does a linkage fold at all?
I should say a given linkage.
So for example, I'll
give you three examples.
Test you out here.
These are rigid bars
connected by hinges.
OK, rigid or flexible?
Rigid, I agree.
Rigid or flexible.
Rigid.
Any other answers?
Flexible, correct.
Both are correct.
In two dimensions, OK, it
depends where you live?
In two dimensions, this
is rigid no matter what,
in any dimension.
But in three dimensions, this is
flexible and in two dimensions,
it's rigid.
In three dimensions,
you can pick this guy up
and it spins around a circle,
out of the board here.
Or you could pick this guy up.
It spins around a circle.
In two dimensions,
though, it's rigid
because it's really
just two triangles.
Triangles are rigid
in two dimensions.
This is a tetrahedron.
Tetrahedra are rigid
in three dimensions.
Rigid or flexible?
Everyone agrees.
In both dimensions
it is flexible.
OK, pretty intuitive
for four vertices.
But you can ask the
mathematical question
and give you a linkage.
Is it rigid in 2D?
Is it rigid in 3D?
And there are many
versions of this question.
But the short version, a
short answer, let's say,
is that distinguishing rigid
from flexible two-dimensional
linkages is easy.
There's a good
algorithm to do it.
It's very powerful, very useful.
In 3D, we have no idea.
Very open.
Tough.
Very tough problem.
A lot of people
have been thinking
about that for decades.
So that's rigidity.
I'm just going to touch on
lots of topics very briefly.
All right.
Next we go on to, I
guess, one and a half.
This is linkages
forbidding intersection.
And this is more
interesting when
you're talking about 3D
linkages like my arm.
I really don't want it
to penetrate other bars.
It's not possible.
And the first question you
might ask in this world, which
I guess is a
foldability question,
sort of a
reconfiguration question,
let's say I want to fold
my robotic arm from one
configuration that
I know-- call it
configuration A-- to some
other configuration, B.
When is that possible?
Can I go from A to B?
Can I go from some other A
prime to some other B prime?
Sometimes yes, sometimes no.
It depends.
Sometimes it's not
foldable at all,
even when you allow
intersections.
So this is a pretty
open-ended question.
In general, it's
computationally intractable.
If I give you a linkage
and two configurations,
to decide whether you
can go from A to B
is, for the
complexity theorists,
piece space complete.
Talk about what
that means later.
Really, really hard
is the short version.
But a lot of the times you can
think about special linkages.
There are a lot of
interesting special cases.
In particular, we like
to think about chains
like I drew before.
Also polygons.
That's a little
messy, but imagine
those don't self-intersect.
So this is what I
call an open chain,
and this is a closed chain.
In general, these are chains.
And the other thing I might like
to think about, in particular
because proteins look kind
of like this, are trees.
Trees are just linkages
without any cycles in them.
So those are nice and simple.
Here I have no cycles,
no cycles, one cycle.
Easier to think about.
And sometimes you actually
get a universality result
that these linkages can
fold from any configuration
to any configuration.
And that's especially cool.
Let me tell you about them.
Where do I want to go?
So it depends again what
dimension you live in.
I'm very flexible in this class.
You can live in
any dimension you
want to, and even
fictional ones.
And you can think about
chains and trees, let's say.
You could go more
general, but this
is where most things
have been studied.
And the answer is,
for chains in 2D
you get a universality result.
You can fold from
anything into anything.
For trees in 2D, you don't.
There are some trees you can't
get from one configuration
to another.
Which ones?
We don't know.
But at least you don't
get a universality result.
In 3D chains you do not
And so also for trees,
because that's even harder.
And for 4D, everything's easy.
Also in 5D, any
higher dimension.
Because the intuition here,
at least for this column,
is you think about tying knots.
I have a one-dimensional
linkage here.
Think of it as a
one-dimensional cord.
It's kind of a kinky cord.
It has kinks-- not the
other kind of kinky.
And in two dimensions,
if you draw
a non-self-intersecting
loop, it's never knotted.
You can't draw a knot
in two dimensions.
You can drawn a knot
in three dimensions,
and you cannot draw a knot
in four dimensions or higher.
You may not know that
result, but it's true.
So it matches, but things are
little tricky, even trees.
If this was a piece
of string, you'd
be able to always fold this
piece of a tree-shaped piece
of string into
anything you wanted.
But it's a little
more complicated.
Let me show you a locked
tree, I think, is next.
Yeah.
For a long time, these were
the only known locked trees.
These are configurations of tree
linkages that cannot reach some
other configuration.
In fact, they can
barely move at all.
It's less obvious
for some of them.
But say, in this
top left one, you
have these little sort of petals
tucked into their armpits,
I guess, and you can't
get any of those arms
open unless you had a
lot of room to open it.
And in order to make
room, you'd have
to squeeze all the
others really tight.
And if you draw this
example tight enough,
also none of the arms can
get compressed very much.
And so it's locked.
And this is one of the first
examples actually discovered
in 1998, and publication
took a while.
There are a few others,
which you see here.
This one's kind of
crazy because it
has only one vertex with
three incident bars.
Everybody else is like a chain.
So it's like three chains
joined together at that point,
and still it is locked.
And for a long time,
these were the examples
we would always carry around.
These are the ones that
appear in the textbook.
But I thought it would
be neat to see, well,
are there any simpler examples?
And last time this class
was offered three years ago,
we found what is believed
to be the smallest
locked tree in existence.
It has 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8 bars, if I counted right.
And it looks curved here,
just to make it easier to see.
But, in fact, you could
straighten these out
and it's still locked.
If you squeeze these
little regions down,
they'd be very tight.
So that was with a bunch of
students from this class.
Cool.
So that gives you some
idea of this answer.
Maybe I'll draw you
a picture for chains,
because it's really simple.
OK, imagine tying a knot, but
don't actually close the loops.
And make these end lengths
really, really long.
We call this the
knitting needles example,
because the intuition was you
have two long knitting needles,
and then a very short cord
connecting them in a knot.
Mathematically,
this is not a knot,
because if it were string, you
could untie it, no problem.
But because of these really
long bars, you can't untie it.
So that's why 3D is hard.
Or one example of
why 3D is hard.
It's pretty much
our only example.
It is the smallest example, and
we can prove things about it.
But there's a pretty
fascinating open question here,
I would say, which
is, characterize
these bad examples.
Which 3D chains and
which 2D trees have
locked configurations?
And all that means is that
there are two configurations,
A and B, for which you
cannot get from A to B.
So this is an example.
Those locked trees
are an example.
It'd be really fascinating
if you could do this.
I would guess that this is a
hard problem, but I don't know.
It's hard to know
whether it's hard.
It'd be nice to understand
3D chains in particular,
because they relate--
and 3D trees.
Oh, sorry.
I have more animations.
I forgot.
Let me show you some pretty
pictures for this result.
This was actually my PhD
thesis, way back in 2001.
And this is a more
modern algorithm
for solving this problem.
I give you some
complicated polygon.
First thing you want
to know is, can you
unfold it into a
nice convex shape?
Once you get there, you could
refolded into some other shape
by playing one of these
motions backwards.
So that's how you
unfold some teeth.
Here's one of those tree
examples, but doubled.
For a while, people thought
that might still be locked,
but it's not.
Can do this crazy fivefold
rotationally symmetric motion
to unfold that thing.
We're zooming in
and out, so it looks
like things are getting
bigger and smaller.
But in fact, each of these bars
is staying the same length,
and they're never
crossing each other.
Here's a much more
complicated example.
This is the first
algorithm that could
handle examples of this size.
It's pretty fast.
That's like it's
going to come back.
You can do it.
It's like a spider.
Spooky.
I think it has 500
vertices, and it probably
took a couple
minutes to compute.
I'm not computing it live here.
There's an applet
on the web if you
want to pick your
favorite polygon
and run this algorithm on it.
It doesn't make quite
movies like in this style,
but it will show
you how it unfolds.
We call this the tentacle.
Yeah, so we'll talk about
this algorithm, how it works.
There's a couple
other algorithms
for solving this problem.
It's pretty cool,
and you could imagine
using this for planning the
motion of a robotic arm in two
dimensions.
But in three dimensions,
things are a lot harder.
We lack good algorithms.
I would like to study
four dimensions actually.
There's some pretty
neat questions here,
but I'm not supposed
to talk about that.
It's not on my list.
I've got to move quickly, but
we're doing all right on time.
What I wanted to show
you was a protein.
This is a particular
enzyme protein
called hexokinase, whatever.
Embarrassing myself.
It's a particularly
complicated one.
It is one of a few I could
find a nice free image of.
But you can see closely,
if you look closely here,
it's a linkage.
And this one actually
has lots of cycles.
But the backbone of a
protein is like a tree,
and so it fits into
this kind of world.
Unfortunately it
fits in this world
of three-dimensional trees,
which are really hard to fold.
Or three-dimensional
chains, if you really
just look at the backbone.
They're a little bit more
complicated than the sorts
of linkages we're
talking about here,
but it makes it even harder
to fold things like this.
But there's something
special about proteins
that makes them
fold really well.
That enzyme over there is
in every living organism
we have ever tested for the
existence of that thing, which
I assume is everything.
And yet it's folding.
It's produced by this
machine-- the Ribosome,
you probably know about it--
in a sort of straight state,
and then it folds into
this shape pretty reliably,
less than a second, usually
like within nanoseconds.
So it's really hard to
watch what's happening.
It's very hot and jiggly,
so it's a little hard
to see what's actually
going on in the real thing.
But somehow, these kinds
of barriers to foldability
don't happen.
Maybe that's because evolution
found the right things,
or maybe it's because
protein chains don't really
look like this.
They don't have these super
long bars and super short bars.
If you've ever played with a
chemistry set, all of the bars
are within a factor of
like 1.5 of each other.
So there's lots of cool
mathematical questions
that come out of
protein folding,
and we will talk
about the ones I know.
I'd love to find more.
But the ones I know
I will talk about.
And that's linkages.
Let me move on to paper,
unless there are questions.
All right.
Let's go over here.
So we've seen some universality
results, some hardness results.
I didn't go into them.
Folding these linkages.
Let's do that for paper.
I think first up I
have foldability.
And then we'll
talk about design.
So there are lots of
questions in both.
But for foldability, the
sort of first question people
like to ask is, which
crease patterns fold flat?
So a crease pattern
is just a graph
drawn on a piece of paper.
So you have some
collection of lines,
and I think that will fold flat.
But I'm not going to try to
draw something more complicated,
but you could imagine doing it.
I don't know.
That probably is
not flat foldable.
It might be.
It's close.
But that's the sort of question.
If you take some
origami and unfold it,
what kind of
patterns do you get?
Some flat origami,
something that
folds into two
dimensions in the end.
There's some really
nice structure here.
If I drew it right, this
angle plus this angle
should equal 180
degrees, for example.
And that's true everywhere.
And there's all sorts
of cool properties.
But unfortunately,
this is really hard.
This is NP hard problem.
You've probably at least
heard of P versus NP.
Again, I'll define it later.
But it means probably
there is no good algorithm
to solve this problem.
It's really hard
to figure out which
crease patterns fold flat.
It's kind of annoying.
One good news is
that if you just
have an example like the
original thing I drew,
which is like this-- so it
has one vertex and a bunch
of creases emanating out,
that picture we understand.
So it's easy for
a single vertex.
That may seem kind of trivial,
but it's actually really useful
because it lets you understand
the local behavior around one
vertex.
If you check that
for every vertex,
you don't know that the whole
thing folds, but at least
you know it mostly
folds, at least locally.
And you can't tell whether
it globally folds correctly,
because that's NP hard.
There are so many questions here
like, what about two vertices?
No one's studied that.
I think it's polynomial,
but well, it's
certainly polynomial,
but I think
you could do it in linear time.
Anyway, there's lots
of open questions
there I haven't
even listed here.
One of the bigger open
questions is a particular kind
of crease pattern, which you may
have encountered in real life
refolding your roadmaps.
The saying goes, the
easiest way to refold
your road map is differently.
So suppose you have your road
map, and each of these creases
is marked.
I'm not going to mark
all them because it's
a little messy with
black and white chalk.
But some of them are marked
mountain, some of them
are marked valley, meaning
you fold-- this is valley.
This is mountain.
So they just have a relative
orientation to each other.
Suppose you look
carefully at your map.
You can recover which
way it was folded last,
hopefully correctly.
And then you want to find,
does that thing fold flat?
Sometimes it does,
sometimes it doesn't.
For two by n maps, we don't
know whether we can even
detect this with an
efficient algorithm.
Can I decide whether
this thing folds flat
using those creases
and those orientations?
For two by n, it's open.
For one by n, it's easy.
Obviously for bigger,
it's also open.
Two by n is the smallest.
This is a really
annoying problem.
Worked on it many times.
It's very difficult.
All right, so that's a quick
overview of foldability.
It's hard, but there are a lot
of interesting special cases
where we might be
able to solve it.
Let's move on to design,
which is probably
where most of the action
is in the origami world,
in the mathematical
origami world.
So and there are
tons of results,
and I had a much
longer list initially,
but I trimmed just for
brevity down to a few things.
The central question--
at least it's
been considered so far-- in
computational origami design
is, what shapes can you make?
You could imagine other
properties than just shape,
if you want stability
in your folding,
lots of practical things--
not much thickness,
not too many creases, whatever.
But shape has sort of
been the fun centerpiece.
And there's an early result
that says universally,
you can make anything you want.
And in the
mathematical world, you
might try to make a polygon.
Try to make a
silhouette or something.
You could make a
polyhedron in 3D.
Maybe you want to wrap a box,
so you want to fold a box,
or you want to fold a
3D model of a dragon.
That's all possible.
And for fun, you can even
make any two-color pattern
on either of those things.
So I have a tiny example
here, which is-- yeah,
it's still alive-- a four
by four checkerboard.
And it's made from
one square paper.
It's white on one side
and red on the other.
So you get some idea of
making two-color patterns.
This one's pretty easy to fold.
It even folds itself almost.
That's great.
Usually when I give a
class like to high school
students or something, I say,
could you refold this for me?
And they're like, oh, no!
But it actually does it itself.
It's great.
Like magic.
So you could try that at home.
Just take a square paper.
It works.
So this is great.
Super general.
This is something actually
my dad and I proved
with Joe Mitchell
back in '99, I think.
I don't remember exactly.
So beginning of modern
computational origami design.
But the way that we do
this, while algorithmic,
is completely impractical.
We'd never want to
use the foldings that
are designed by this algorithm,
unless you're starting out
with a big ticker tape of paper.
Then it's a great method.
But if you're starting with a
square, the first thing it does
is fold it down to a
tiny little narrow strip,
and then wraps the shape.
And we'll see how that's done.
It's interesting to
do it mathematically,
but it's not how you want
to do it practically.
Good news is-- that used to be
sort of the end of the story.
But now you can even do
it pretty practically--
practically is a
relative term-- using
something called Origamizer.
And if you've seen the poster
of this class, you've seen--
and if I'm lucky, it's
even the next slide,
yes it is-- this rabbit--
bunny, I should say.
This is the Stanford bunny.
The original Stanford
bunny is in the top right.
That's a classic model.
Everybody in computer graphics
does something with that bunny.
It has a zillion triangles.
I don't know offhand how many.
It's been simplified
here to make
it feasible to fold to
this mesh of triangles.
So the input to the algorithm
was this mesh of triangles.
The output of the algorithm--
and it's a real program,
you can go and download
it right now for free--
is this crease pattern.
Now it doesn't look
like a square or paper,
but if you start with
a square of paper,
you just fold away
the excess stuff.
You'll get to a piece
of paper like this.
And then you just fold along
all those little creases there,
and eight hours later
you have this bunny.
This is a real photograph
of a folded bunny
by Tomohiro Tachi, who
designed this thing.
He came up with the original
algorithm and computer program.
In the last few
years, we've been
proving this algorithm
actually always works.
We still don't know how to
prove that it's efficient,
or even what
efficient should mean.
But in practice it's super good.
If you look closely,
the white parts
are the parts of
the paper that you
need to use in
order to make this.
They are the triangles
of the surface.
These grey regions
are the excess.
And it's pretty small.
I don't know, maybe 50% of the
area is used in a useful way
here, which is a lot.
Whereas this method
over here would use
like a one millionth
of a percent
of the paper or something.
A very tiny amount.
The Origamizer is
super efficient.
We don't know how to prove
that it's super efficient,
but at least we can
prove that it works.
It will make any 3D
polyhedron you want.
And in practice, it
seems really good at it.
Now it's a very different
style from typical origami,
so this has not yet hit the
sculpture world, let's say.
But I think it opens the door
to a lot of new possibilities.
Traditionally
though-- traditionally
before this Origamizer
or in practice
today, a much more
commonly used approach
to computational
origami design is
something called
the tree method.
I'm just going to call
it TreeMaker here.
TreeMaker's the name
of the program that
implements the tree method,
and it's made by Robert Lang.
And this is sort of making
stick figures, which
sounds a little silly.
But TreeMaker or the
tree method is powerful
for if I want to make what's
called an origami base, that
has a lot of limbs in different
places of different lengths--
maybe you want to make
something like that.
I don't know.
The typical origami base might
look something like this.
Maybe you want to make a lizard.
It has a head, some forearms,
some really big hind legs,
a little tail, and some body.
You can abstract
this into a tree
and then say, well can
I fold a piece of paper
into some shape
whose projection is
that tree, with all
the right edge links?
And the answer is yes.
I mean, you can make
anything, of course.
But what TreeMaker tries to do
is find the most efficient way
to make that thing.
Unfortunately, finding
the most efficient way--
like the smallest square
paper, so the most paper
usage possible to make
something with that projection--
finding that is NP complete.
We just proved that this
year with Robert Lang
and Sandor Fekete.
But there's a theory.
There's a hard problem
you have to solve,
something related
to disk packing.
If you solve it, you
find the best way.
In practice, use some heuristics
which are really good.
And usually you
find the optimal way
to make a given stick figure.
But for super complicated
things, it may not be perfect.
Now a lot of people use this
method for designing origami.
I have a slide of cool
origami, just to show you.
Not all of this uses
the tree method.
These three designs
by Brian Chan,
who was an MIT grad student,
graduated last year--
these are all designed
partly using the tree method.
I'm sure they're more
complicated than that.
But to get the initial structure
of the arms in the right place,
the legs in the right place,
the head, body segments,
fingers-- some of
these guys have
fingers-- all that stuff
is done using tree theory,
almost certainly not with
TreeMaker, the program.
Most origami designers do it by
hand, in their head, or drawing
pictures with a drawing
program, to design out the base.
Then they fold by
hand everything.
But still, the math is in there.
These guys are not yet
mathematically analyzed,
let's say.
They're experiments by
[? Garn ?] and Joel Cooper.
[? Garn ?] is a computer
scientist slash mathematician,
but he doesn't understand
these yet, and sort of he's
trying to figure it out.
So there's a lot of
interesting questions,
and you get some really
cool sculpture as a result,
out of this world.
So this is something
we've also been working on
with my dad and Robert Lang,
proving that this actually
works.
It's been around
for a long time,
but it turns out to
be really complicated
to prove that it always works.
But it looks like it
does, so stay tuned.
Some time we will
publish that paper.
It's still in process.
All right.
I have some more fun things.
This is just a random selection.
There's a ton of work here.
One of my favorites-- this was
my first result in this field--
is the folding cut
problem, theorem, whatever.
So you start with a rectangle
of paper, and you fold it flat.
Now you take your
scissors-- I know
this is blasphemy
for most origamists.
But I'm not going to
make a lot of cuts.
I'm just going to make
one complete straight cut.
I get two pieces in this case,
and then I unfold the pieces
and see what I get.
In this case I
get a little swan.
And the general theorem is you
can make any polygon you want.
In fact, you can
make one cut and make
any collection of
polygons you want.
So like on my website,
you can make the MIT logo
with all the little rectangles
with one complete straight cut.
And the outside
shape will have holes
exactly where you want them.
And you can download
this, too, if you
want to impress
all your friends,
especially recommended
for, like, kids.
It's a good magic trick.
In fact, Harry Houdini
used to do this trick
in the '20s before he
was an escape artist.
He did general magic.
Not this trick.
He made stars.
And we thought about it, and we
proved you could make anything.
So that's fun.
Another universality result.
It's what got us started.
And it relates to things
like the tree theory,
in fact, because what
you're really solving here
is, how do I take a polygon
and-- if I fold this guy back
up-- how do I make all
the edges of that polygon
lie along-- this
guy's not very happy,
get rid of that-- lie
along a straight line.
That actually turns out to be
important for origami design.
A lot of these things--
an Origamizer--
it's all over the place.
And so this structure
is helpful for solving
sort of pure origami
problems, not with cutting.
So what else do I have?
Curved creases.
You may not know this,
because most origami
is straight creases.
But if you take
a piece of paper,
you can put a curved
crease into it.
It's a little hard to do
by hand, but there you go.
Curved crease.
Is that allowed?
What can you make like that?
It's not too well studied.
Jeannine Mosely has done some
of the curved crease stuff.
Early stuff was done
by David Huffman,
you may know from Huffman codes
in every cell phone, whatever.
And by Ron Resch.
That's wrong queuing.
All right, I'm going
to show that later.
This are some of the
things that we've made,
this is my dad and I,
out of curved creases.
This is kind of a crazy-- it's
like a circular piece of paper,
but it goes around
twice like a ramp.
So you make two circles
and then join the ends,
and you pleat along
concentric circles,
alternating mountain and valley.
And you change a few
different parameters,
and you get these
three different shapes.
These are in the permanent
collection at MOMA in New York.
So you can make some really
cool sculpture out of this.
This is a more
recent piece we did.
And this is taking just a
regular circular band of paper
with concentric
circular creases,
and then taking three of them
and joining them together
at a few points.
And then you get
some cool structures.
These are interesting to us
especially because the paper
actually does fold itself.
You put in these
circular creases.
You just squeeze
a little, and it
will make these
shapes automatically.
It's called
self-folding origami.
And in that spirit,
I will show you
a different kind of
self-folding origami.
I think I need to
click this button.
Which is approach to making
paper that folds itself.
This is a self-folding sheet.
It's made of rigid panels
connected by little rubber
hinges, and there's little
muscles, you could say,
that are folding
those creases shut.
By turning on some
electrical signal,
that thing folds
itself into a boat.
That same sheet, you can send
it a different electrical signal
and it will just fold
along these two creases.
And then there's little
magnets to hold it into place,
so you can turn off
that electricity now.
No power.
Then you send it a third signal,
and it will fold those three
creases, and you get
a paper airplane.
No origamist required.
So the idea here, this is the
programmable matter vision,
where you could download
hardware in the same way
you could download software.
You can make one sheet that
has lots of panels in it,
enough creases to make
anything you want.
And then you just push a
button and some of the creases
turn on.
Then push a button and
some other creases turn on,
and it folds into some
complicated origami
all by itself.
You could imagine making
this building scale.
You could imagine making it
nano scale, some scale where
an origamist can't
do it, or you don't
have an origamist
to do it for you.
This would be the
self-refolding, transforming
robot thing.
To do it, though, we
needed to prove new theory.
And this is the world of, call
it, universal hinge patterns.
And this is the topic of a
master's thesis just finished
last week, I think,
by [? Viva Vadia ?]
where-- and maybe
we'll get him to talk
about it at some point--
it's one crease pattern.
In that case we were using
a crease pattern called
box pleating, where
you take a square grid,
and then you put alternating
diagonals in those squares.
Get my alternation going here.
So that's the so-called
box pleating pattern.
We proved that that pattern,
if you make it big enough,
can fold any 3D shape that's
made out of little cubes.
I think, yeah, so in fact if
you take a sort of n by n sheet,
you could make about n cubes.
And in the worst case,
that's the best you can do.
So that's cool,
because that tells
you here's one robot you build.
You just make this sheet
with those creases,
those rubber creases with
muscles on each of those edges.
And if you can turn those
edges on and off programmably,
you could make anything you
want up to some resolution.
If you want to make a
bunny, you can sort of
build that bunny our of
little cubes in simulation,
and then fold that cubefied,
voxillized form of the bunny.
And then you want to
make something else,
you unfold it and refold
it all automatically.
AUDIENCE: This is
like [INAUDIBLE]
no width of the material?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, there's a
lot of open questions here.
This result assumes 0 thickness.
In fact, every result
I've talked about
assumes 0 thickness.
I think there's one theorem
in the literature that
looks at thickness of paper.
That's a great open
question, and you really
see it in something
like that video.
That just appeared at PNAS,
and the video's online.
Because in the
airplane, you have
to fold through multiple layers.
And that's tricky.
We get around that right now by
having the creases be a little
bit stretchy, some rubber.
But there's a limit, and it's
related to the thickness.
So yes, some complicated shapes
are not going to work this way.
I think one thing that
would work really well-- we
have another result with Jason
Ku, which is folding a maze.
This is sort of like folding
a shallow terrain in this way,
so you could make a rat maze
out of a square-- just tracks
by 50%, and then
you have arbitrary
undulation in the middle,
which is pretty cool.
So some of these things
are going to be practical.
Some are not.
So there's still interesting
theory questions to ask about.
I think thickness is
a really good one.
Other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I thought
I heard something about how you
can't fold a sheet of
paper more than like--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
that's the one thing.
The question is, you can't
fold a piece of paper in half 8
times, 7 times, whatever the
number is everyone quotes.
The answer was solved by
someone who was a high school
student a few years ago.
What's her name?
Britney Gallivan.
And so this is the one paper
that's about thickness,
and she analyzed-- the issue
is when you fold-- if you have
a folding that is
1,000 layers thick,
and you want to
fold in the middle,
you can't just like cut here
and move it over here and then
be folded.
Paper has to actually
turn that corner.
And the thicker that thing
is, the more length of paper
it takes to turn that corner.
And you can compute
how much that
is if you assume sort of
a circular trajectory,
and it matches reality.
So she computed how thin does
a piece of paper need to be,
or how long does
a piece of paper
have to be-- it's
that ratio-- in order
to fold it in half 12 times.
So she took a piece of
paper that was, I think,
three-quarters of a mile long,
and folded it in half 12 times.
And it's like this big
monstrosity when it's done.
And it follows the
theory exactly.
So that seems to
be the right model,
but that's the only
paper that analyzes
paper folding in that
model, because it's so much
easier to think
about zero thickness.
But that is what we should do.
So that particular
question we understand,
but everything else is open.
I'll show you some
pictures of that next time.
Other questions?
All right.
That is paper, and
then I was going
to show you a little bit
about polyhedra and hinged
dissections.
All right.
Let's go.
So I mentioned there's a
bunch of different kinds
of polyhedron folding
and unfolding problems.
Probably the coolest
one-- because it's
the oldest problem in
this entire field--
is unfolding convex polyhedron
by cutting along the edges.
We call this edge
unfolding convex polyhedra.
At the beginning of
class, I showed you
a cube which you could
unfold into a cross.
I want that.
So I was only cutting
along edges of the cube.
That's this edge unfolding.
The cube is a convex shape.
It doesn't have any dents.
And I got to unfold it with
one piece without overlap.
Is that always possible?
We have no idea.
Can every convex polyhedron
be made in that way?
We don't know.
This problem goes back
to Albrecht Durer,
this guy on the left.
This is his self-portrait.
In 1525, he wrote this book
called The Painter's Manual
in German.
And he tried this out for
a whole bunch of polyhedra.
This is the so-called snub
cube, and unfolded in his book.
And he has page after page
after page of these unfoldings.
And they're all edge unfoldings.
Most of them are correct.
There's a couple small
errors, probably just
transcription errors.
And he did this
because he wanted
to understand these 3D shapes.
He had to build them.
How do you build them?
So he didn't pose this
mathematical question.
He was not a mathematician.
But it's sort of implicit
there, and people
have been thinking about it for
at least decades if not more.
At least since '65, I think,
was the first formal posing.
And it's really hard.
A lot of people
have worked on it.
We'll talk about it.
There are some interesting
things that are known.
I mean the depressing
thing is we
have no algorithm which
we think will work.
Every algorithm we've tried
has a counter example.
Every counter
example we've tried
has an algorithm
for which it works,
but they don't match
up, so it's frustrating.
If you allow
non-convex polyhedra,
then the answer is no.
So that's something I did
with a bunch of people
back in the day.
This was actually
done in '98, then
it took forever for the
journal paper to appear.
This is a polyhedron.
All the faces are triangles.
So it's sort of
topologically convex.
And then if I made the
spike a little shorter,
it would be a convex polyhedron.
But this particular embedding--
these are just two views.
If you cross your eyes,
it's three dimensions.
No, I'm just kidding.
It's not designed for that.
Just two views of
the same thing.
And if you cut along the
edges any way you want,
it will overlap itself
or be multiple pieces.
And we'll prove
that at some point.
It's not too hard.
Yeah, so good.
That's edge unfolding.
But there's another
kind of unfolding
called general unfolding.
This seems a lot more
interesting to me.
Edges are sort of artificial.
What if you let me cut
anywhere on the surface,
not just at the edges?
Well, then it turns out,
for convex polyhedra,
you can do it.
It's always possible.
I don't have pictures
of that here,
but even for some non-convex
polyhedra you could do it.
For example, this
polyhedron, if you
let me cut not just at the edges
but anywhere on the surface,
you can do this crazy thing.
These are the spikes, and you
cut out a tiny little sliver
out to the side,
and that lets you
attach one of those spikes
from one of these witch's hats
to the wrong side.
Like you see, this blue guy, the
blue spike-- because this edge
ends up being
glued over here, we
can attach the spike with
the little sliver that
gets opened up here, over
there, and avoid overlap.
Even if these spikes
are super tall,
does this go out to
infinity and overlap.
That's one example.
Can you do it for every
non-convex polyhedron?
We don't know.
I would love to
answer that question.
The one thing we know or
the big thing that we know
is so-called
orthogonal polyhedra.
This is always possible.
This the same kind of
thing I was talking about.
You take any 3D shape
made of little cubes--
so all the faces are horizontal,
vertical, or the other way--
then it's also always possible.
The current method takes an
exponential number of cuts.
It's really impractical.
I think we could
make it practical.
I think we could generalize
it to everything.
But those are all
open questions.
One more picture I
wanted to show you
is, so here we really want
to keep the shape connected.
You have to have a
positive area of connection
between everything.
If you let that connection
go down to a single point--
sort of cheating, this is
called vertex unfolding--
and then it's possible for any
surface made out of triangles.
So it could be
non-convex, anything.
These happen to be
convex polyhedra.
It's a little hard to see that
they're three-dimensional,
but they are.
You cut them up
into little faces.
Here I'm only
cutting along edges.
And I string them
out on a line here.
This thing will not
overlap, but I'm
kind of cheating because
the connections are only
at single points.
But hey, we'll take a positive
result if we can get it.
A lot of these problems
are really hard.
OK, the next thing
I want to talk about
is the reverse
direction folding.
So we know-- this is
a video I made back
when I was a grad
student, a long time ago.
So we know you can take
a cube, and there's
a whole bunch of different ways
to just cut along its edges
and unfold it into one piece.
And the particular
unfolding I want to consider
is the cross unfolding,
because that's our favorite.
So you take this
cross unfolding,
and ideally don't stutter.
And you say, well what if
I gave you that polygon?
What 3D shapes
could it fold into?
One thing is the
cube, but it can also
make this flat doubly
covered quadrilateral.
So I'm taking this
as a piece of paper,
but I can set the
creases however I want.
I can fold it into this
five-sided, reflectionally
symmetric polyhedron.
All of these things are
convex, and they all
have perfect coverage,
unlike an origami where
I'm allowed to have
multiple layers.
Here, one layer everywhere.
Like sheet metal bending.
So here, this pocket fits
perfectly into that tab.
I make a tetrahedron.
And the last thing you can
make with something called
edge-to-edge [INAUDIBLE]--
I'll talk about this more.
There's an algorithm here
which, given a polygon,
will list all of the
things it can fold into,
in a reasonable amount of time.
This is an octahedron.
Those are the five
things you can
make by edge-to-edge
[INAUDIBLE] of the cross.
Let me stop that.
So that's also on the web.
You can watch it.
In fact, all the lecture notes
I use, my handwritten notes,
are on the class web page.
The slides that I'm showing
And when there's videos,
there's links to the videos,
so it's all there for your
perusal if you miss something.
The last thing I wanted to talk
about, because I've already
done one, two and three,
there should always
be one more thing.
Fourth thing.
And this is kind of funny,
because I don't really
know where to put it.
I'm still figuring it out.
We have these
debates, because it's
so easy when you're
thinking about linkages.
Oh, that's one dimensional.
Paper, that's two-dimensional.
Polyhedra, well locally
it's two-dimensional,
but it's three-dimensional.
It's different.
Different questions.
Hinged dissections span
so many dimensions,
I don't know where to put it.
So four, hinged dissections.
This didn't used to be
a topic in this class,
and it's not a topic
in our textbook,
because the result was proved
like last year or the year
before out of this class.
Three years ago.
And the theorem is you take
any finite set of polygons,
of the same area,
they can be folded
from one chain of polygons
without collision.
I'm going to say this
first, and but let me
show you a simple example.
Very simple.
This is going to
be a little boring.
Let me show you more
interesting example.
Let's take an
equilateral triangle.
I'm going to cut it
into two triangles,
and then I'm going to
hinge them together here.
So this is now a hinged
chain of polygons.
If I open it up a little
bit, it looks like this.
It looks a lot like
those vertex unfoldings
I was showing before.
And you can fold this
thing into one other shape.
It's going to look like this.
Not a very good drawing,
but you get the idea.
Something like that.
So this is what we call
a hinged dissection
from this equilateral triangle
into this other triangle.
And it's been an open
question for about 100 years.
Can you always do this for
polygons of the same area?
Turns out yes, not
only for two polygons--
you can take seven
polygons of equal area
and there's one of
these chains of blocks
that can fold into all of them.
And I think I have
a little teaser
picture of how the
construction goes.
It's really crazy.
You have this chain of blocks.
It's changed in a particular
way and you say, well
I really want that green piece--
so think of it like this.
You just have three triangles or
three pieces that you can fold.
You say, well I really like
that green piece to be up top.
Turns out you can make
all these crazy cuts.
And if you fold it this
way, you get the green piece
on the bottom.
If you fold it this way, you
get the green piece on the top.
It's one hinged dissection that
can move the pieces around,
and basically pretend as if
the hinges weren't there,
and make anything you want.
So it's a bit complicated,
but it's really
cool theory, something that
we worked on for like 10 years
before finally solving.
And it's practical.
I mean this particular
construction isn't practical,
but this is another way
to build transformers.
Also to build sculpture.
This is a sculpture by Laurie
Palmer that we collaborated on.
It's an interactive sculpture.
You pick up gloves, and
this is one chain of blocks.
And the theorem is, this
particular chain of blocks--
about 1,000 blocks here--
can make any shape made out
of about 250 cubes.
It's slightly skewed, but so
there's one hinged dissection
that can fold into exponentially
many different shapes-- again,
anything made out
of little cubes.
And this is the
sculpture version.
We also have various
prototypes of a robot that's
a long chain of little cubes
or cube-like shapes, that
can fold itself into
any 3D shape you want.
It's, again, a different
kind of transformer,
more inspired by
proteins, the way nature
does it by long chains,
compared to the sheet-folding,
origami-inspired approach.
But it's all pretty
exciting and fun.
Any questions?
Jean?
AUDIENCE: This is a 3D version
you were talking about.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I
pulled a fast one.
That picture's 3D.
This is about 2D.
For 3D, you need the same area.
You need one other
condition just
for them to have a dissection.
It's impossible to go from a
regular tetrahedron to a cube.
This was one of Hilbert's
problems from 1900.
And volumetrically
it's impossible to go
from regular
tetrahedron to a cube,
because the angles are wrong.
It's an algebraic thing.
And if you make things out
of little cubes, it's fine.
You get that.
There's no problem.
But in general, there's
some tricky issues.
It's easier to state for
2D, which is why I did,
but it works in 3D, too, with
a little extra condition.
And we'll talk about
that in the future.
Other questions?
All right, that's the
end of lecture one.